the spider-man Disney Sony deal
continues spider-man is such a huge and
very important Marvel character which is
why many of the fans want him to remain
in the MCU and there are a lot of
reports going on right now stating that
the deal is done and that it was open
back up again and now there are reports
saying that Apple could buy Sony which
would make the rights to spider-man go
back to Disney but that is still a long
shot as we have no idea if Apple really
is going to buy Sony but today we have a
little bit more hope we have a report
today that says Disney may just outright
buy spider-man from Sony now this is
different than what they've done before
before they just tried to get 30% of the
revenue and profits that spider-man
earned but now Marvel and Disney want to
buy spider-man outright from Sony this
is something that actually has been
attempted before but unfortunately
didn't work out so I'll dive into
everything that needs to happen for
Disney and Marvel to buy the rights to
spider-man outright from Sony quick
heads-up I'm doing a CO giveaway with my
buddy Kaos he's going to start to do
some different types of Marvel and pop
culture videos on his channel so if
you'd like a chance to win a Nintendo
switch be sure to subscribe to my
channel and his channel and of course
subscribe to my channel to enter for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 so as
I mentioned Disney and Marvel trying to
buy the rights to spider-man back from
Sony outright has happened before if
this would happen that means that Marvel
and Disney would own all of spider-man
and that means they can do whatever they
want with him without Sony being in the
picture because they would own all of
the rights to him and that means
especially keeping him in the MCU as a
future leader of the future Avengers now
according to reports Disney and Marvel
tried to buy spider-man outright from
Sony in the past but Sony wanted ten
billion dollars now ten billion dollars
is an insane amount of money so of
course Disney and Marvel said no but now
according to reports it seems like
things have changed and Marvel and
Disney may go back to Sony with a lower
number in an attempt to buy the rights
to spider-man
now although 10 billion dollars is an
insane amount of money for a character
right now spider-man is definitely worth
a high number spider-man far from home
was the first spider-man movie ever to
make over a billion dollars now
this was widely due to the fact that
Spiderman was in the MCU he was an
Avengers infinity war and he was in
Avengers in game which is now officially
the highest-grossing film of all time
and this was sort of Marvel's plan when
they introduced him in civil war for him
to be a part of the future of the MCU
and now with the possibility of Apple
buying Sony and makes sense for Sony to
try and sell the rights to spider-man to
Marvel and Disney because if Apple by
Sony the rights the spider-man go back
to Marvel and Disney and Sony would not
get any money for spider-man but
unfortunately if a company does decide
to buy Sony it will take a very long
time most likely a couple of years so
unfortunately if that happened Spiderman
would sort of be in a limbo state which
is what Marvel and Disney do not want so
right now it makes sense for Sony to
sell the rights out right back to Marvel
and Disney for spider-man and apparently
Marvel and Disney are going to come up
with a different number that is lower
than 10 billion dollars and presented to
Sony in hopes to buy back spider-man
this is almost the best-case scenario
because like I said if a company by Sony
that doesn't happen overnight there's a
lot of legal processing that has to be
done for that so it will most likely
take between a year and two years to
finish so that's a year to two years
that Disney can't use spider-man and
Sony gets no money for spider-man if
that happens but if Sony is willing to
sell the Reds to spider-man back to
Disney and Marvel for a lower price then
we don't have to wait for spider-man to
be in the MCU and Sony still gets money
for spider-man
so hopefully this ends up being somewhat
true hopefully soon Marvel and Disney
will make an offer to Sony to buy
spider-man and hopefully Sony will
accept that would officially bring back
spider-man to the MCU but let me know
what do you all think about this right
now it's a lot of back and forth between
where spider-man is going to end up so
let me know would you like him to stay
in the MCU because I know there are some
people that would really like for him to
stay with Sony and stay in the VIN
numbers so be sure to let me know in the
comments down below again don't forget
to subscribe to my channel and head over
to Kaos and subscribe to his for your
chance to win a Nintendo switch and be
sure to subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment with your
favorite superhero or villain for your
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof